So let's talk about measurements.
What are the things that
start-ups should measure?
>> Such an important question.
It's actually the first
conversations we have with
start-ups when they
get into Y Combinator.
The first time we sit down with
them we say, what's your metric,
because Y Combinator runs for
three months.
They get in, it's really four months
from the time they get in, five months
from the time they get in but,
they have demo day at the end of that,
when they get up in front of a roomful
of very intelligent people, and
they show their progress.
And the more progress they can show,
honestly, the better that demo goes and
the better their follow
up conversations go.
So, you have to figure it out and
it's different for every company.
Now, there are variations on themes,
right?
There are basic themes
that everyone looks at.
If you're a company that
should be generating revenue,
your metric is probably revenue.
If you're a social product,
it's probably users or
some function of engagement.
If you are a transaction site, it's
probably something about the number of
transactions you do or the volume of
transactions, which by the way is
just a proxy for revenue, because
you probably would take a cut of it.
So it's particular to
different startups.
I think the critical thing is
to make sure it's the thing
that actually reflects whether or
not you're succeeding as a business,
and not what we call vanity metrics.
>> And what's the hard part about
setting the metrics and measuring them?
>> Everything.
Right, so I think on one
level it's hard to choose.
You start out as a company and
you think to yourself, oh,
there's all these different things
I want to accomplish, right?
I want to hire people,
I want to raise money.
Raising money, by the way, probably
the biggest vanity metric of all.
Basically meaningless for
the success of your company,
except that it gives you money
to achieve the metrics you need.
So, you think that, you think that,
you want a lot of people,
you want a lot of press,
you want all these things,
and they all feel good, but they don't
necessarily matter to your business.
So that's the first part.
Ignoring all that vanity is hard.
The hardest part, though, is once you
pick a metric, being honest about it and
sticking to it, and
setting time frames for
success and for
progress that you actually stick to.
So, we tell companies that during
Y Combinator they should grow
whatever their metric is between 5 and
10% a week.
We try to say go for 7% a week.
If you do more, great.
If not, not.
And that's great for consumer companies.
And if they're sticking to that,
the thing that happens,
and this is something
that people miss a lot.
They say, oh,
all you care about is growth.
But, growth isn't
a one-dimensional thing, right?
Growth is a function of the fact that
you've done everything else properly.
You built a product that people want,
you got it into their hands,
you supported it, it continues to
be something that they want to use.
That's what leads to growth.
So you can't, you can't isolate it.
And if you miss it, that's when it gets
hard, because then you have to be honest
with yourself about why you missed
that goal, why you missed you metric.
And that will make you
fix your business.